[Musique]
c'est dans cette serre sur le toit d'un
immeuble donne sic que louf a récolté
ses premiers légumes il y a dix ans
[Musique]
depuis l'entreprise en aménager trois
autres une à laval une anjou et une
autre à saint laurent mais pour le
fondateur ce n'est que le début de l'
aventure à notre vision c'est de
développer un modèle qu'on peut
appliquer partout dans le monde quand on
est pas encore là alors on a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire
[Musique]
avec une superficie totale de six
terrains de football les serres lufa
produisent plus de 25 mille kilos de
nourriture chaque semaine l'entreprise
compte aujourd'hui 600 employés dont
javier qui est là depuis le début je me
sens vraiment
en tant que chef des cultures il veille
à ce que les légumes poussent dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
j'ai mis toutes mes efforts et mes
connaissances comme on le nomme à des
ddd aussi à sept projets de grandir
loufoque qui n'avait que deux cents
abonnés au départ livre maintenant plus
de 25000 pagny chaque semaine
l'entreprise à former des partenariats
avec d'autres producteurs pour
diversifier son offre et offrir une
véritable épicerie en ligne aujourd'hui
on est capable de personnaliser tout le
contenu du panier et on a aussi apporté
plusieurs producteurs et les producteurs
alimentaires et maraîcher à sur notre
plateforme web
marie-hélène demers est une fidèle
cliente depuis cinq ans elle a été
conquise par la philosophie d'entreprise
et par ses produits les légumes frais
c'est des aliments frais c'est local
la livraison se fait par des voitures
électriques
j'ai tout mon disque il ya vraiment du
prêt-à-manger au tac que mon pain qui
m'ont les mais tout est bio alors pour
moi c'est vraiment manger bio manger
bien selon ce consultant c'est grâce au
flair de son fondateur que lufa est
devenu un succès il ya vait
définitivement un besoin auprès auprès
des consommateurs pour un concept comme
celui là monsieur à je veux juste en
avant de la vendre à son projet et des
projets lufa en a bien d'autres
l'entreprise veut s'implanter aux états
unis avec l'ouverture d'une première
sert à boston il ya beaucoup de
similarités entre le boston-- morial ccd
vie qui sont très ouvertes à
l'innovation et c'est pas des grandes
villes nécessairement alors on voulait
s'assurer qu'on a quand même une bonne
chance de succès dans notre première
aventure à l'extérieur du québec lufa
veut aussi poursuivre son expansion au
québec une autre sert sur toi verra le
jour dans le grand montréal il y a aussi
un projet spécial dans les cartons tenu
secret pour le moment
olivier vache un réseau canada montréal